それでこの怠けの対治法ですね
治療法 で なんでいきなり怠けのことを喋りますかと
あの矛盾は怠けから出てくるんですよ
なま だから怠けがある限りはろくなことにならないんですよ
新しいものを開発すればするほど
人生はもう大変なんで楽になりません
複雑になってしまうんです
最近 インテリビルという概念があるでしょ
だから ビル自体があらゆる機械をつけちゃって
カーテンも自動で開け閉め閉めるとかね
するとかね 会社からもう自分の家の暖房冷房をつけられるとかね
そんなことになってみると
ちょっと何かあったらどうやって修理修復できるのかと
ちょっとだけでもプログラムに何か異常が発生しちゃうと
もう建物に入ることさえもできなくなっちゃうんです
水も出なくなっちゃう
ガスも出なくなっちゃう
これが大きなプログラムにしようと思ったうちも
2 週間かかるそうとか言われるとどうなるんですかね
あの昔風に そこらへんの木で切ってきて建てた家だったら
自分でも修理できるのにね
だからやっぱりこの怠けこと
怠けることの発展っていうのはどうにも矛盾だらけで
もうなんか非夫人なんです
だったらお釈迦様はそういう先生の怠けなくなくしましょうと
治療法は体に治療することから始まる
心に怠けあるんだけど
体に治療することから始めなくちゃいけない
二次的な怠けがありますからね
私って不幸やとかね で
面白くないとか 人生はとかね
いろいろ二次的な怠けがありますね
それから直す場合は 論理的に箱に最初に入れたものと
もう箱から出す場合は
最後に入れたものは最初に出すでしょう
だから順番は逆になりますからね
だから怠け治療は体から始まるんです
しかし 運動 スポーツは怠け思考から出るアイデアなので要注意
それで では体から怠け取り除そうと思った途端
どなたの頭にも浮かぶのは
では毎日 1 万歩ある散歩をすればいいんじゃないかとかね
あるいは月 2回ぐらいスポーツセンターに行ってスポーツすれば
体を鍛えすればいいんじゃないか
それで体が怠けないと思ってますけど
あれが違うんです あれが怠け思考から出てくる考え方なんです
体力あればもっと怠けるんだぞと
だって健康でいて よくバリバリ仕事をして金儲けて怠けるんだろうと
ぐちゃぐちゃの思考なんです
だから私はこちらでいう体の運動っていうのは
決してスポーツでもないし
運動でもありません 簡単ですよ
3番目に書いてます 姿勢正すのです
姿勢正してみてください
簡単でしょ 常に正しい姿勢でいる
人間の心の怠け 見えるところはそこなんです
だから心の曲がり方を見たら
我々性格まで言うんですよ
結果として必ず怒られますから
だってみんなに隠してると思ってるんだからね
これいきなり会って 3 分で言うと
やっぱり腹が立つでしょう
気持ちはわかります 本人は隠してるんだからね
隠してるものは人にバレるといい気持ちにはなりません
隠してるつもりですけどね
だから体の姿勢で性格までわかる
この肩の形 首の置き方
手足の置き方でもう見事にわかります
それで我々勘違いするのかと
しないんです 例えば 肩に構造的に問題がある場合は
特に肩の骨が折れちゃって
またつなげた時はちょっと下がっているとか
そういうのは全然わかります
この人の骨組みには問題あるんだよと
それは簡単にわかる でも
肉体的なところで心の怠け
性格に見えます 怒りの人とか
欲張りの人とか 1 日中妄想ばっかりしている無知な人とか
あるいは妄想しなくても
あれこれとか 世の中のことをあれこれと考えている
ずいぶん思考型の人間いるんですね
思考ばっかりして混乱している人か
あるいは何でもかんでも簡単に信じる信仰型かと
で もう体見たらもうわかるんです
だから姿勢直してほしい
姿勢直しちゃうとわからないんです
他人にバレません こんな簡単な方法ってあるんですかね
お金もかからないでしょう
１円も 誰にでもできるでしょ
姿勢っていうのも 座る時の姿勢がある
歩く時の姿勢がある 立ってる時の姿勢がある
寝る時の姿勢がある それを守ってみてください
ものすごく怠けがなくなるんです
例えば 仏教では寝る姿勢っていうのは右肩にで横に寝るんですね
上も向かないで 下を向いて向いて寝るんじゃなくて
仏像にありますね あの画像の仏像のね
横になって この右の方を下に入れて寝るんです
夜寝てみてください きちんと足をまっすぐにして
しっかりして こういう風に
どうなるのか まずできないと思うでしょうに
もう怠けの塊なんです
それで心に欲やら怒りやら
もう怠け もうあらゆるあることによって
寝る姿でも変わるんですよ
人の性格は寝ている時見たらもうもうわかったもんなんです
何者かと だからそうやってバレないんですよ
こうやって誰でも同じスタイルだから
そうすると その寝方しても
最初はこんなもんで寝られるわけじゃないんだよと思うでしょうね
それ 怠けなんです そう思うことも
でも これは正しいお釈迦様がおっしゃっている修行だと
これがまあ このお経をあげたり
お線香を立てたり いろいろ巡礼に行ったり
八十八ヶ所を回ったりするでしょうに
それよりも優れている修行だと
思って その聖なる気持ちでやるんです
ただいびきかけながら
よだれ垂らしながら もう気持ち悪い
寝るんじゃなくて 自分が修行中であると
心清らかにしているんだということで
ちゃんと右を入れて寝てみる 1
日やってみたって経験が違うと思いますよ
まず寝る時間がじーっと縮むんです
まあ寝つくまでは時間かかりますけど
その間は呼吸を整え 唱えたりとかね
慈悲の瞑想したりとか
自由に考えられるんですよ
こうやって仰向いて寝ちゃうと
何考えてるかわからないんですよ
怒りやら憎しみやら 失敗したことやら
もういろんなことが頭に入るんです
汚れるんです こうしていると
その思考まで管理するんですよ
特別な姿でいるんだから
思考も特別になるんです
あの人憎いとか あの人と仲良くしなくちゃいけないんだとか
そんなのは出てこないんです
だから その始めた時点から心はもう直し出すんです
直り始めるんです それで寝つくためには時間かかる
その時間の間で心の整理できるんです
呼吸瞑想するなりに 慈悲の瞑想するなりにすると
そうするとちらっと電気が消えたように寝るんです
自分も知らない いつ寝たかと
短い時間で目がパチッと覚めるんです
ああ まただるいとかね
それはない いびきはかかない
よだれは垂らします 寝返りは入れません
それで８時間寝るでしょうに
これ４時間に縮むでしょう
この４時間で何かできるでしょうに
熟睡している ほか何か
だから寝る時も姿勢がある
立つ時も姿勢がある 座る時も姿勢がある
これ守ってほしい 怠けがなくなるんです
そこで人間は性格的に弱くてだらしないんだから
ただ言った瞬間でみんな背筋をピンと伸ばすでしょうに ３０
秒持てないんだから それで私を騙されていると思うんで
その上 だから私はずっと嫌味言わなくちゃいけないんですね
陸をなめるなよと 人を誰を騙しちゃっても
これはできないんですよ
だからもう正直でいいんです
正直というと 人間っていうのはだらしないってことをもう知ったことだから
全然批判も何もしません
騙そうと思っちゃうと
もういくらでも言うんですよ
嫌味は で そういうことで
この維持することが問題ですよ
それで維持するためにはずっと精神力必要なんです
集中力が必要なんです
体を意識しないとできないんです
でも 大胆なスポーツじゃないでしょ
体にもよろしいし 健康にもよろしいし
見た目は格好は抜群にいいし
誰にも性格はバレませんし
背筋を伸ばしている人は人格的にも伸びているんです
しっかりまっすぐなんです
からくりはない インチキはない
信頼できる それは姿勢直すことで成り立つの
しかし まあ十秒ぐらい
三十秒ぐらいだったら
誰にも猿にもできますよ
猿でも犬でも立ちなれて立つでしょうね
訓練したら でもあれは維持できないでしょうに
我々どれほど苦労しますかね
犬に待てということを教えるために
楽じゃないんですよ 待てという一言葉
犬に教えることは でも犬の場合でも
待てと言ったら３0分でも待つ犬っていうのは結構頭がいいでしょ
頭が悪くて馬鹿犬だったら
もういくら待てと言ったっても
言う前にもう食べてるんです
あげる前に飛んで もう手からもう取って食べていったりするでしょうね
それでわかりやすいでしょ
性格も頭が悪いんだと
犬の場合でも頭がよくなると維持できます
だから頭がいいか悪いかとかの維持なんですよ
コンティニュエーションということ
そこで犬が待てと言えば
自分の目の前で美味しい食べ物があるんですけど
あれ 待てっていうことを覚えてすってるんです
だからすごく頭がいいっていうことになるんです
そこで姿勢３０秒直すことは誰にでもできますが
これがずっと維持してほしい
座っている間は正しい座り方で座っている
歩く時は正しい姿勢で歩く
曲がる時も いろんなものを取ったり
いろんなことをする時でも
美しくその姿勢でやるんです １
日やってみたっても もう信じられないほど結果が出ます
今日１日でやってみるんだよ
皆様にはもうもう天才的に脳が働くんですよ
それしか脳の勝手に脳の開発にないんです
便利な万人に通じる方法っていうのは
仏教の出家した場合は
この戒律というものがありまして
それで戒は少ないんです
項目ですから 律はもう多く単義であるんです
すべて行儀作法なんです
いかに正しく歩くか 正しく座るか
正しくご飯を食べるか
正しく服を着るか そういうものをずっと教えているんです
それで怠け者たちは それは別にどうったことない
そんな単純なことをといって無視するんです
だから出家の仲間からはもうもう不可触民族扱いするんです
いかにこの姿勢が大事かというと
それが悟りにつながりますから
私は５回守っているんだそう
私は１０回守っているんだと言ったっても
それほど心に影響ないんです
行儀ちゃんと守っているんだよと言えば
もう 戒律の中でもお風呂の入り方なんて説明しているんです
大便小便の仕方 何から何まで衣のたたきたたみ方
で 鉢でご飯を食べたら
もう鉢を洗わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
で 水はどうやって捨てるのかと
そこまで言うんだ 水を捨てる場合は
葉っぱの上に草の上に捨ててはいけない
外で昔の戒律だから外でご飯を食べる
その場合は どこにも散らかさないように
自分の足元も一滴も水が飛んでこないように綺麗に出さなくちゃいけないんです
そちらにも心の管理がいつでも必要です
鉢っていうのは丸いやつだから
そこを手で洗うんですよ
水は飛んでいってはいけないんです
ゴシゴシゴシゴシでやっちゃいけない
水のまま水が自動的に回ります
その自動的に回りに合わせて洗うんです
一滴も飛ばない そこまで厳密に行儀作法を教えているんです
だから姿勢 それ全てまとめれば姿勢なんです
一言葉で言えば だからそんなたくさんやらなくてもいいんだから
まあまあ 最低歩く 立つ
座る 横になるという四つだけでもやってみれば
1日頑張ってやってみると
信じられないほど我々精神的に向上しているんです
頭がよくなっているんです
脳がビシビシと活動しているんです
そうすると怠けがなくなっちゃうんです
で その維持するためにね
これは仏教でいうサティなんですね
心は常に 気づきを実践しなくてはならないという羽目になるんです
そこでこの怠けの定義なんですけど
まだ続きありますけど
私は怠け者ではありませんとみんな言いたいでしょ
あれ 怠け者ではなくて慌て者なんですよ
落ち着きがない せっかち
精神的に混乱している
だからもうドアをパッパとドアを開けるは
物を取るは また片付けはまた入れるは
あちら走るは こちら走るは
もうきりがないんです
動きは 自分がもう怠けは嫌だよと
もう庭でも野菜も作るは
もうすごい分 一日中は忙しい
これ一日中忙しいっていうことは
単なる混乱しているだけで慌てもんで
ただ汗垂らして働いたんだからといって怠けがなくなったわけじゃないんです
なぜ汗たらし働いて働いたかというと
怠けるためだからね 矛盾のいいところですよ
だから人が一日中どこかに座っていたんだと言ったっても怠けじゃないんです
座っている時は姿勢正しく座ってそれを維持する
それだけで怠けがないんです
お釈迦様の定義は 今の瞬間に気づいているのかと
手を挙げている場合は
手を挙げているんだぞということに気づいているんでしょうかと
歩く時は歩くことに気づいているんでしょうか
食べる時は食べることに気づいているんでしょうかと
だから  1 秒単位で気づいていることが怠けがない状態なんです
頑張るかないか それは関係ないんです
一日一万歩歩くかないか
それはどうでもいいんです
それは仏教の定義なんです
怠けっていうのは すごい深い意味で
この心の心底にある このある性格を取り除こうとしているんです
はい はい 次に行きます
これ治療法で続き 質が悪い怠けが瞬時には消えません
で 瞬時に消えるんだったらね
もうがん摘発摘出みたいな感じで
瞬時に消えるんだったらありがたい
それは瞬時に消えるわけじゃないんです
体にあるんだったらすぐ捨てればいいんですけど
残念なことに これ性格的なところで心にあるんですよ
だから瞬時には消えません
だから やっぱり時間をかけて姿勢を正さなくちゃいけないんです
姿勢を維持することと
徐々に怠けが減るのです
姿勢を維持すると 徐々に時間姿勢正しくいれば
その分怠けが減っているんです
その減り具合に合わせて心が生き生きしてくれるのです
だから嫌な気持ちがなくなっちゃうのです
すごく楽しげられます
心は生き生きしているんです
怠けがなくなると 怠けが減ることで
文化的な物質的な発展ではなく
人格的な進化が起こるのです
姿勢を維持して あの 380 キロ
時速 380 キロで走れる望みは開発ではないんです
そんなのは怠ける人が考えることであって
見栄張り人が考えることであって
でも猿はそのままでしょう
だからこれで人格的に発展があるんです
向上があるんです 人格的に
だから私は進化と発展を区別したんだから
人格的な進化が起こるんです
だからただ姿勢を直す
それだけで我々は人格者になるんです
きちんとそこら辺は覚えておいてください
やってみて嘘だったら言ってください
あのクレームしてください
もうそれはもう効き目がないんだぞと
だから仏教っていうのはいつでも証拠とともに喋ってるんです
こんな全て折り紙付きなんです
効き目は 100%で 外科医でも 100%ないでしょうに
体のもういろんな部品切って捨ててるのに大丈夫でしょうか？まあそこそここれぐらいだったらまあ 60パー 80%とか言うんだから
もし自分に運がよく あの 20%に当たったら死ぬでしょうね
これはもう 100% 80%で成功します
はい で それから次のタイトルです
もう怠けの大量はそれで終わり
怠けの治療法は それにこの進化を目指せということですよ
発展じゃなくて あんなのは矛盾でしょうに
発展すればするほど人生苦しいでしょうに
だったら進化を目指しましょう
発展なんかは現状維持の努力です
それ分かったことありますか？考えたことがありますか？発展と現状維持ということは
初めてかもしれません
覚えておいてください
人間はずっと文化的な
科学的な 経済的な発展を目指していたでしょうに
あれが現状維持なんです
今の現状を維持するためにということで
いろんな発展 だから人間の進化が止まったんです
我々はいろんな機械を作って体を変化させないことをしているでしょうに
例えばもう速くは走れない
犬なんかは速く走る だったら人間は毎日犬と一緒に競争したならば
三世代になってくるとみんな足が速いんですよ
三世代で四世代でもう足が速い
その代わりに我々は自転車から車から飛行機まで発展しちゃったんです
だから足が速くなるどころか
もう現状維持でそれも退化するでしょうね
今歩くことはできんだから
だから発展というのは
せいぜい新設して言えば現状維持
もうちょっと辛口で言えば人間退化させるんです
刺激もなく面白くもないんですよ
この発展というのは 現状維持でしょうに
だからみんな退屈でしょ
あの なんとか衛星テレビなんかありますね
チャンネル 100ぐらいありますけどね
すべて退屈で面白くないでしょう
怠けに攻撃することで人格の進化を目指すのです
だから怠けを正当化している発展ではなくて
怠けを対峙する 攻撃する
それで我々は発展するんじゃなくて進化するんです
常識では想像できない幸福を体験できる
この物質文化では考えることもできない幸福を人格進化で体験できるのです
脳が動いてくるだけでも
楽しく 楽しくて楽しくてたまらないでしょう
あの この科学発展とか機械発展とか面白くないんですよ
ずっともう十年も研究してくっだらない何かを作っただけだから
だって機械のネジでも微妙なあれで機械の機能が変わるでしょう
でも期待通りに動かない
それでまたバラして また一つ一つ調べて調べて
どこでしょうかとか それでやっと見つかる
あ このネジはもうちょっと細くなった方が良かったとか
あるいはこの丸目はこうではなくて
ちょっと楕円形になった方が良かったとかね
そんなつまらないことなんですよ
でもかなり苦労してるんです
だからつまらないんですよ
結局は 脳が動いているということは
それでは想像できないほど面白いんです
そこでは人間の次元も人間の次元も超えて解脱を体験できる
人間発展しすぎちゃではなくて
進化しすぎちゃって人間を乗り越えてしまうんです
だから怠けやぶっちゃうと人間を乗り越えてしまうんです
それがお釈迦様がおっしゃっている進化の道なんです
発展の道じゃないんです
仏教の悪口言ってるのはそういうわけではなくて
ヨーロッパがあれほど発展しているのに
仏教の国々は何も発展していないんではないかと言うと
我々の反論何か知ってますか？でもあんた方は猿でしょうと
人間できてないでしょう
昔は平気でやっていたんです
車とかなんとか作ったっても
食器に薬使ってご飯食ったっても
人間に争う 文化人じゃないんだと
猿だと 今はあまりも凶暴でちょっと言えないだけ
だからこの進化するんですよ
で 付け加えて 私は瞑想しますけど
私は瞑想を指導するときはみんなに言うでしょ
この0点5ミリで微妙に背筋を伸ばしてください
そこで微妙に背筋を伸ばして
聞いたことがない方々もいるかもしれませんだけど
体がまっすぐになったところで微妙に体を上げてもらうんです
胴体を 微妙なんです ほんの気分的に
ほんのまっすぐにして
ほんのちょっと上げてもらう
立ってるとかいりませんだけど
ほんのわずか もしくは0点もう 0 1 ミリぐらいかも
このわずか胴体を上げて
そのまんま維持するんです
座っていると  30分座っているんだったら 30
分もその姿勢 自分で体を運んでいるんです
地球の引力には任せない
その微妙なところで人間は進化します
我々は猿でいた時は 4本で歩いていたんですよ
それで猿がすっごく頑張って立ってみたんです
もう倒れる 倒れるんだけど
でも立つ またバランスを崩してまた倒れる
でもめげなかったんです
とにかく立ったんです
立っていると筋肉もできて
立っていることはできたんです
長い時間 その間に脳が開発したでしょう
立ったところで みるみるうちに
他の動物よりも人間の脳が大脳が見事に開発してしまったんです
だったらもうちょっと立てと
それから立つことをやめたんです
今曲がってるでしょ そのほんのちょっとやらないんです
それから発展しようと思っているんです
だからこの赤ちゃん 立つでしょ
あれ 大変な努力なんですよ
でもめげないでしょ 立ってもすぐこけちゃうし
でもまた立つ 時々何かに頭
頭重すぎでしょうし 頭何かにぶつけてえらい痛い目にも遭うでしょうね
大体人間でもすごい痛い目に遭っちゃうと
もうやりたくないでしょう
もう怖くて 赤ちゃんはそれでもめげない
頭ぶつけたらもうキャーキャーと泣くんですけど
またすぐそれを忘れてまた立つ
そこでもう大体 1 分ぐらい立っていられるようになる
それでまたもう倒れちゃう
またどんどんその時間がちょっと伸びたら
1 分ぐらい立つようになったら
もう足一つ出してみるとするでしょう
出せません 足を上げた途端またこけちゃう
でも頑張るでしょうね
だからそこで明らかに脳の発展なんですよ
だからこの瞑想する時は厳しく姿勢を伸ばして
そのまま固定しなさいと
ぐにゃぐにゃしてはいけませんというのは
そういうわけ ヴィパッサナー瞑想で
仏道で そのもので 何にチャレンジするかということ
怠けにチャレンジしているんです
それが減るともう見事に開発する
爆発的に ということで頑張ってほしい
はい 次に行きます 進化の利点は何なのかと
なんでそんなにも進化しなくちゃあかんかということをね
裏面で起こる悪影響 副作用なんかはありません
今の世の中 矛盾だらけでしょう
ほど発展しているのに
また何か探しているでしょうに
私たちのところに来るでしょうに
あれがこれがいろいろ文句言いながら
こんなに世界は完璧で問題なかったら
誰も宗教に行く必要ないでしょうに
でも本を読むは人は探すは哲学は読む
あれこれと矛盾だらけなんです
どこからも理不尽なんです
この副作用 何一つもない
悪影響は何一つもない
人間が進化して何が悪影響でしょうか
発展してみてください
もう地球が破壊するかもしれません
それがない 一概に善なのです
一概に善 良いこと 例えば原発はいいかといえば
一概には言えないでしょう
石油の問題なく まあ一時的に自然破壊することなく
まあエネルギーはできますというところだけ利点であって
あれ一時的で あの放射物質はどうするかということは
またものすごい問題が出てくる
事故を起こしたらどうするのかという問題もある
テロが起きたらどうしようかという問題もある
誰かに何か盗まれたら
この放射性物質なんかをどうしようかということもある
だから原発は素晴らしいということは言えないでしょう
では 薬は素晴らしいですか？でもないでしょうに
薬は病気な人の問題ですけど
病気にかかっている人は薬を飲まなくちゃいけない
だから薬は完全に善だと言えますか？言えません
ご飯は完全に善だと言えますかね
言えません 何一つもこの世の中で完全に善とは言えない
みんな副作用 悪影響を持っている
すべて しかし 進化は一概に善なんです
だから姿勢正すこと 一概に善
何も付箋が入っていない
それで得るものではなく
なるものです 発展というのは得るものでしょ
車買ったそうとか 電子レンジを買ったそうとか
得るものです だから自分のものじゃないんです
部品です これは進化という自分がなるものです
だからなくなりません
したがって維持する苦労はありません
すごくいい利点ですよ
我々は家を買ったっても維持する苦労あるでしょうに
税金払ったりいろいろあるでしょうに
何でも維持しない 服を買っても維持する苦労がありますよ
仕事を見つけても仕事を維持する苦労があります
結婚したっても 結婚生活を維持する苦労はそうとうあるんです
でもなるものではそれはない
自分はなったんだから
外から来たものではないんだから
そのまんま楽なんですよ
完全安全なのです 完全に進化というのは安全なんです
生きる目的の最終点です
なんで生きるのかと これは
ゴールなんです 進化すれば
だからそれで全ての我々の努力は終了する
全ての努力終了するためには
怠けを完全に取り除かなくちゃいけないんです
怠けがある人には 修行終わった
やること終わったと 面白い
羨ましいなと思うんですけど
その状態に達するためには怠けを捨てなくちゃいけないんです
まあ大体そこら辺だと思います
はい 次ありますかね まあ終わり
話は 人は物理的な発展ではなく
精神的な進化を目指して努力するべきなのです
ということは結論です
物理的な発展に頑張るんじゃないんです
精神的な進化を目指すんです
はい まだありますかね
終わると思いますけど
それでお釈迦様の言葉は
わやめいてはポリソヤーアッタッサミッパダ
目的に達するまで人は努力するものなのです
と途中で諦めないでください
一番難しいのはこの怠けを絶つことなんです
だから姿勢を維持することも結構大変ですよ
でも目的に達するまで諦めずやらなくちゃいけないということは
お釈迦様がお坊さんたちに言った言葉なんです
はい で 終了です では 一応お話はそこに終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
では あの ご祈祷の時間の質疑応答の時間したいと思います
今のお話 何かご質問などある方
特に あの体  心が怠けて体に影響があって
さらに体からまた心が不幸に感じるという
あれで上からどんどん外していって
まずその体のその怠けを取り除いてしまうということですけども
その上の二次的な心の怠けが上に乗っかってしまったら
その その 要するに二次的に発生する心の不幸というやつが乗っかってしまうと
その 何ていうか 体をそのきちんと保っていくという
その努力自体が破壊されてしまうように思うんですけども
その一番二次的に乗った一番上のその心の不幸というものは
これ乗っからないんです
だから一番最初にそれがなくなるんだだから例えば 5分でも姿勢を伸ばしたままで置いておくと
その分じりじりと神経働いて
もう二次的な怠けがなくなるんで
その分気分がいいんですよ
だから頑張った自分を褒めるんですよ
自然に 5分もできたということで
だから二次的なことは問題にならないんです
だから二次的なことをまた攻撃したっていうことは
その瞬間でもう姿勢壊してるんです
自分がとっくに怠けて維持することは仕事をやめて待ってる間
気づく それで気づくんですよ
それがこの二次的な怠け
また攻撃したっていう話になるのはそれなんです
攻撃しない 二次的な怠けは最初になくなっていくんです
一番上のものだから だから攻撃されてまた負けちゃったという人が
それをもうこれが攻撃したんだから負けたんじゃなくて
最初からもう自分がもうサボってるんです
仕事を そのサボった間で二次的な怠けが攻撃しているんです
マーラに隙間があるんです
その瞬間に 例えば眠気が出てなかなかうまくいかないというと
眠気が出る前に姿勢崩してるんですよ
怠けが入ってちょっともう緩めているんです
その時間ある  1 分  2 分経つと
もう眠気が出ているんであって
眠気が出て瞑想できなかったという話ではあります
それはやっている人そう言うんだけど
厳密にはそれは正しくないんです
他にございませんか？どうぞ
今 生活習慣病ということで
どうも糖尿病などについて非常に力を入れていて
私も少しあるような感じだったんですけども
先ほど運動は食事療法と運動をしっかりすれば
糖尿病は克服できるそうなんですけど
先ほど運動ということは
運動しなさいっておっしゃるのですが
先ほどのお話の中で運動ということがちょっと私わからない
なるほど だからこの運動しなさいというのは
俗世間の人々の話ですよ
医者やらね そこら辺に座ってる人々は運動しなさいと言うんであって
彼らが基本的に怠け思考だから
怠けるためにどうしようかと
だから運動して糖尿病とか何とか治ったらまた怠けるぞという話なんです
だから矛盾なんですよ
私は運動はダメと言ってる話じゃないんです
ご飯食べといけないって言ってるわけじゃないんです
で この生活習慣病っていうのも怠けから出てくるんです
だから怠けを足すためには姿勢を直すということなんです
だから姿勢を直していくと
運動よりもかなりエネルギーを浪費する
エネルギーがものすごく強化するんですよ
精神的に強化すると細胞がもう治るんです
だからこの方法でも結構治りますよ
姿勢を正しているっていうこと
はい こちらの方  ちょっと姿勢とは関係ないんですが
断食を修行の一方法にしている宗派みたいなのがありますが
あれは  あれは表面的にはもう怠けを足すということですけど
欲を足すとかね でも そういう断食みたいな特別な儀を唱える場合は
結局怠け思考にもなるんですね
断食したら健康になるんではないかと
もっとご飯をおいしく感じるんではないかということも言い出しちゃうんですよ
結局は体が健康になるんではないかと言っちゃうと
もう元に戻った話になります
また あまり偏りすぎて不自然なんです
体っていうのはずっと秒単位でエネルギーは使ってますから
エネルギーは適度に一定のスピードで与えた方がいいんですよ
呼吸と同じなんですね
呼吸も体にずっと必要でしょうし
だからどうしてもやりたいとやって悪くないんだけど
厳密な心理に論理にはならないんです
で 断食する人はそれなりに 1 日 2 日か 1 週間ぐらいね
頑張るんだから これは精進努力ですよ
でもそれでよかった これから美味しく食べるぞとかって思っちゃうと
元にまた戻ったことになります
仏教ではないんですからね
断食っていうことに はい
あのあの仕事では精進料理ということをよく主張して
やっぱりこれも同じような
まあ大体似ていることでね
だからその精進料理のことを言う人々がどんな思考でそれを言うのかということを考えなくちゃいけない
例えば 生き物の生命を絶つのはもう悪いでしょうと
生命はみんな平等でしょうという慈しみだったら
まあ評価できるんですよ
ではなくて 健康にいいんだと言っちゃうと
もう勝手にしろと ということになるんです
それはそういう精進料理を唱えている方々の思考
考え方によるもの によるものなんです
いますよ 肉よりは精進料理の方がすごくおいしい
とか言って また欲を唱えたりする
だからそうすると掃除した別に意味がなくなっちゃうんです
はい  姿勢の話に戻ってしまうけれども
あの年を取ってきて 物理的にちょっとお腹がなってる人間に対して
また姿勢を真っ直ぐにしろとかいうと
つい背中曲がっちゃうんですけど
人ったら人間に対してはどの程度もそのできないというか
それはできないんです
その時はまあ私だったら
その人にまずやらせてみて
体をチェックするんです
チェックすると この方には精いっぱいはここら辺だよとわかります
例えば 年のせいで体曲がることは怠けということじゃないんです
それは筋肉が弱くなったんだからのだけのことで
それは怠けとしては選んでいません
はい  仕事中とかでも姿勢を正しながらデスクワークなんですけど
仕事を背中をまっすぐしなくちゃいけないっていう頭が 2個に分かれちゃう
仕事  仕事をしながら姿勢を崩さないように仕事をした方が
日々の行動を習慣として姿勢を正しながら仕事をした方がいいとは思うんですけど
なんかつい仕事の方へ行くとつい姿勢が曲がっちゃったりとかして
あ いけないいけないとか
常に乱れちゃいそうな
それは精神力の馬力の問題なんですよ
精神的な馬力が少ないんだから
仕事に行っちゃうと もう体に入れるエネルギーがなくなるんですよ
体を姿勢しちゃうと エネルギーがそちらに行って
仕事にはエネルギーがなくなるんですね
だからまあ 1時間ぐらいは苦労した方がいいんです
姿勢を直して立たせている間は
エネルギーは浪費しないんです
浪費しますけど そのエネルギーを浪費することでエネルギーを生み出すんですよ
これはこの発電機と同じなんです
発電機はモーターを回すためにエネルギー使ってるでしょ
でもすごいエネルギーはもう出してるんです
だから引き算で言えばかなりプラスなんです
だからモーターでも最初に回すのは大変ですよ
だからこの努力して もう姿勢をまっすぐにして仕事をするんだということになると
この体に意識がいるでしょ
それが集中力になるんですよ
集中力になって仕事は簡単にいくんです
だから最初のスタートはね
なんとか頑張らないとうまくいかないんです
で 馬力の問題です それは
はい  寝る時の正しい姿勢っていうのが
右を下にして右手を上げて
左手はどこに  まっすぐにしておくんです
足はどのように揃えるのか
足はぴったし揃えなくてもいいんです
ちょっとずらすでもいいんです
右の方の足の上に左足を置く
一応置きますけど ちょっとずらしてもいいんです
ほんのちょっとあまりではなくて
気持ちいいところまでちょっとずらしてもいいんです
右やったことがないので
右足の上に左足を置いたままずっといると
なんか左足が落ちるような気がした
それはいくら落ちたってもいいんです
それは大体ほんのちょっとずらすんですが
1 センチぐらいとかね
大体落ちません  右 右手を下にする場合
この手のひらがどの辺りに
それも適当にこういうこれぐらいでもいいんです
適当に 自分で分かりますから
やってみるとこの方が楽だなということがありますから
例えば私の場合も この耳がなんかこうやってロバみたいに出ているんだから
結構痛いんです 耳がそうなっちゃうと
時間経つと私は耳がこうしちゃうんです
で こうして寝るんです
そうすると指がそちらに入っちゃうとあまりもきついんだから
指はここら辺に置いておく
その場合 枕は使わない
枕使うんです 枕使うんだったら手が枕の下に入れてもいいんです
ただ形だけしっかりする
寝ることだから まあいくらか楽でないとね
まあいけませんから 手を枕の下に入れてもいいんです
どんな時か  はい 車を運転している時の正しいというか
理想的な姿というのはどういう
運転したことがないんだから
私は 私の知識で言えば
正しい姿勢でしか運転できないはずなんです
大体このバスなんかで運転手見るでしょ
プロの人々 ものすごいぴったりかっこよく座ってるでしょうね
ちゃんとハンドルを握ってこうやったりとかね
タバコ吸ったりとか全くしないでしょ？ジュースを飲んだりあれとかね
すごいしっかり座って
その運転できるように座席もできているんだから
まあそれまあこれはそんなに難しくないと思います
その時でもやっぱり首ぐらいはまっすぐにした方がいいんです
たまにこのあまり運転しない人とか
こうやって前にいたりもしますね
で 例えば後ろを見るともう体まで曲がったりもするでしょ
そこら辺のロスなんですね
だから今はあんまり後ろを見なくたっても全部見えるようにね
できているし だから周りを見る時でもまっすぐ座って
こうやって見て こういう風に見るとかね
そういうのは車運転の場合は正しい姿勢だと思う
運転の経験ないんだから
あまり大胆なことは言えません
この間 冬岡さんが来た時に話を先生の姿勢の話のことをしたんですけれども
先生がこの姿勢を最近はよくっていう話を冬岡さんと話して
で こう禅とかの文化から日本文化が派生して
それで姿勢を正すから
日本の一応文化はそれで成立してたんじゃないかなという話をしたんですけども
そのどうしてその日本のその姿勢を正すっていう文化が
その要するに正しいその心の成長につながらなくて
こう今みたいな堕落する方向に向かってしまうようなことになってしまう
堕落する方向へ行ってないんですよ
いまだに それがこの日本の姿勢を正しくするという日本の文化が日本人だけの文化を作ったでしょ
国際的にも誰にも負けない
だから日本人にいまだに威張れるところはたったそれだけでしょうね
車なんか作ったって もうとっくに誰かが作っているし
最近なんかあの伸びる紙を発展しているんだと
だからいろんなものに使えるんだと
あのプラスチックの代わりに
この食器の代わりに あのプラスチック
あのあれ 弁当とかね そういうもの何でも使えますよと
で それはもう大変な技術だと証明して説明しながら
これはイタリアで開発したもので
日本の会社が買ったんだと
ということだから 威張れないんです
結局は本格的には では
茶道やら書道やら花やらね
これはもう誰にも文句言えないんでしょ
日本の庭園とかね だからこの例えば
特にヨーロッパから日本に来るのも
日本の文化を目指してくるでしょ
だから日本の禅寺なんか行ってみたら
まあ外国人の数が多くて
日本人の数が少ないというところになっているし
だからこの日本人には威張れる自慢にできるというところが
やっぱり姿勢 文化から出ているんです
だから問題は なぜそれは心を随分清らかになるところまで行かなかったっていうことはね
まあそこはもうどんな人間にもある弱みだと思います
日本人だけということではなくて
深海に行くともう頑張らなくちゃあかんだから
どこかで止まって まあいいやということになるんです
また怠けが入り込んじゃうんですね
それから日本の場合の問題は
このあまりにも形式化するでしょ
あれは厳密に形式ですね
茶道なんか見るともううるさくて
もう形式ばっかしで この精神的なところはこの科学的なプロセスだよっていうことはわからない
です これは厳密に科学的なことやと
この心の怠けを取り除くことであると
だから肉体はどうったことはないんだと
これは二の次やということを覚えてないんです
肉体は一で終わりもそこで終わっちゃうんですよ
だからそこら辺でまた俗世間の考え方に陥ったんです
姿勢美しく正しくっていうことになって
もうストップしちゃったんです
だからこのそれだと思います
問題は この裏に厳しい法則があるんだよっていうことはわかってない
だから こちらで仏教の狙いはかっこいい人間を作ることじゃないんです
人格を発展させるではなくて
進化させるということなんです
人間を乗り越えなさいと
いかに美しい日本庭園を作るのかっていうことではないんです
無を無ということは石で表現するとかね
そういうまた物質世界に戻ってるんですよ
だからそこら辺でストップしちゃったんです
だと思う うん はい  姿勢を整えての相談もあるんですけど
例えば犯罪を犯した人ですか
ちょっと聞こえない 犯罪
仏教の国で犯罪を犯して
例えば刑務所に入った人たちとか
そういう人の姿勢のことで仏教に習ってやればいい
っていう  聞えなかった
刑務所でそういう姿勢を正しくしろとか言ってるか
仏教的な思想で  だから刑務所でのこの何されるかというと
大体時間に起きる 時間に食べる
時間に寝る ちゃんと姿勢正しく座ると
そういうことをいくらか問題されてるでしょ
だからまあそれなりに育てたとは思っているんです
刑務所の側は だから姿勢正すと
いちいち説教しなくても
それなりに人間はまともになります
それはこちらで言う通りになると
もう完璧にまともな人間になります
だからこちらの私が言ってる姿勢っていうのは
この生ぬるい生半可な姿勢じゃないんです
本当に簡単なんですけど
実際は しかし 精神的には生半可な気持ちでできるものじゃないんです
たった 30 分でも背筋を伸ばしたままでいるっていうことは
かなり精神的な力が必要なんです
それできる人はだいたい罪を犯しません
常に落ち着きがあります
集中力が だから悪いことはしません
ということでしょうかね
わからない うん はい  禅宗のお寺で座禅をしてた時に
お坊さんがピシャッと頭を叩かれた
やっぱりその姿勢を正すという
今までのお話  それまあ同じそれなんですよ
姿勢が曲がるともう叩くでしょ
それでまた伸ばして起きます
で それでしっかりしますよ
頭もすごく冴えてきて
で ある一定の時間はそのままでいられます
で ちょっと問題点言うならば
お坊さんに頼っているんですね
だから完全に怠け取り除けるかということは問題なんです
指導者がいないとやる気にはならないっていうことは怠けですからね
だから正しく言えば 任せっきりでやらせないといけないんです
修行者に 勝手にしなさい
お釈迦様もやるけど そういうこと
まず教えてあげて 森にあるんじゃないか
そこら辺に木の下あるでしょうと
私にできることをやりましたから
行って頑張りなさい 見張りはしない
そうすると本人が自分で頑張らなくちゃいけないんだから
完全に怠けがなくなるんですよ
で 禅宗のお坊さんたちがやることでは
修行に入る方々は この方策に頼って姿勢を直しているんだから
ちょっと依存しているんですね
依存の時点で怠けが残る
はい  ちょっと聞いて 声を大きな声で
初めてこの会場に参加させていただいたんですけど
じゃあ座禅と瞑想はどっちがいいですよね
どちらも知らないです
これが難しいんだからね
質問の答えとしては ちょっと
そんなに違うところはないんです
座禅の場合は 座ってどうするのかっていうことは説明してないんです
で 私たちの場合は 座った人はどうやって心を育てていくのかというプロセスがあるんです
それだけの差なんです
座禅というのは そう 当宗の座禅はきちんと背筋を伸ばして
きちんと足を組んで手を組んでじーっと座っている
それで心は無にしなさいと言うんです
しかし どうすれば心が無になるのかということは言わない
だから座っている人は形だけ保って
頭はこんがらがっちゃうということもあるんです
大変疲れます こちらで言っている瞑想の場合はそうではなくて
ずっと結構仕事はあるんです
やる仕事 その仕事をやることによって
心はきちんと整理整頓されて発展していくんです
そういう差なんです  そろそろ時間にはなってきましたけど
何かまだ見残していることは
あの怠けというのは 貪瞋痴で言えば
痴に属してます  はい それで最後のお言葉
あの報告されているタイトルと
これは何やと思うかもしれませんだけど
見事に論理的に成り立っているんです
で 要領が内容があまりにもポイントありすぎて忘れると思いますけど
人間の危険性っていうのは
私は内から現れる現れるんだよと言ったんだよ
だからあなたの目は安全でしょうかと言う場合は安全じゃない
あなたはいつでもすごい危険であると
その危険性 どっちがなるかというと内にあるんだよと
それは怠けだよ 怠けがあるとあなたは破壊するんだと
例えば日本はもう贅沢な生活
もう坊ちゃんばっかりになっちゃって
北朝鮮がもし攻撃したら
もうあの軍隊にも何もできないんですよ
もうお腹いっぱい食って遊ぶしかしか知らないんだから
能力ないわけじゃないんだけど
戦う能力はないんです
技術能力はある で それだったら日本が潰れるのかと
それは外から来て潰すことできないんですよ
日本人の思考がさらに怠け思考になっちゃって
北朝鮮人を侮辱することになったところで
頭が悪くなっちゃって
判断できなくなったところで攻撃が出てくる
もしそれがあるならば
ないと思いますけど あくまでも仮定の推測の話です
もし北朝鮮が日本を攻撃したならば
それはあくまでも日本人の心に原因があるんです
それで自分が来てちょうだいと招待しただけなんです
こちらが落ち着いていて
物事を明確に判断できて
しっかりと国の国民の幸せを目指して頑張っているならば
向こうは何も攻撃はしない
だから 外からあまり攻撃はないんです
外から攻撃されてもよくわかるんだからね
外から来る攻撃だから逃げられますよ
でも心の中に敵が潜んで住んでいるならば
もうわからないんですね
だから仏教から言えるのは
この外の敵ではなくて
自分の心に定住している敵を発見して追い出してくださいと
それで全てのものに勝ったことになるんだよということで
のテーマなんです だから私はずっと説明したのは
この心の中にあるこの毒
心の中にあるこのウイルス
心の中にある敵の話なんです
だから それを取り除かない限りは
我々の身は安全ではありませんということを最後に言いたい言葉です
どうもありがとうございます
では 最後に回向の文を唱えて終わりたいと思います
回向の文 仏法の三宝に大感謝し
パーリ語にチット念処とヴィパッサナー修行によって伝えたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向します
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得ますように
サッビーティヨ ヴィパッジャントゥ サッバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ マーテー バワットアンタラーヨ スキーデー
ガー ユコー バワ バワトゥ サッバ マングラング ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバ プンダヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマヌバーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティ バワントゥ テアビ
ワダナ シーリッサ ニッチャンワッダパチャイナ チャッターロ ダンマワッダンティ アーユアンノースカンバラン
では終了いたします どうもありがとうございます